wenn eure pflanzen so aussehen oder so
dann seid ihr in diesem video genau
richtig dann habt ihr nämlich mehltau im
garten und was man dagegen unternimmt
sowohl gegen den echten mehltau als ob
gegen den falschen mehltau das zeige ich
euch heute in diesem video
man unterscheidet also zwischen zwei
unterschiedlichen varianten vom mehltau
der echte mehltau ist der schönwetter
pilz mit dem wir dieses jahr
wahrscheinlich kaum zu kämpfen haben
dann ist dieser weiße belag den man auch
mit den fingern ab treiben kann den man
auf der platte oberseite vorfindet den
bekommen vor allem die gurken kürbisse
und zucchini aber auch karotten können
den zum beispiel bekommen und
schwarzwurzeln können ihn auch bekommen
der falsche mehltau ist so ein brauner
pilz rasen er ist auf der unterseite der
blätter daran kann man die also schon
sehr gut unterscheiden der eine ist weiß
und oben der andere braun und unten und
beim falschen mehltau bekommen die
blätter später dann auch gelbe flecken
und sterben dann wenn sie stärker
gefallen sind auch einfach vom falschen
meter sind noch ein paar mehr gemüse
betroffen den können zum beispiel auch
unsere kohlpflanzen bekommen auch die
radieschen der spinat die ärzten und
natürlich auch gurken zucchini und
kürbis und eine sache die man
unternehmen kann und die richtig gut
funktioniert ist wenn man nicht nur
mitte mai einmal alle gurken und
zucchini pflanzen raus selbst sondern
die gurken und zucchini pflanzen die man
pflanzen möchte aufteilt auf zwei
termine und mitte juni dann noch mal
frisch vorgezogene pflanzen direkt ins b
pflanzt oder ende mai nochmal direkt
welche ins freiland ausfällt weil das
den vorteil hat dass die pflanzen die
schon älter sind also die man mitte mai
gepflanzt hat dann irgendwann im lauf
der saison gefallen werden es dann aber
noch jüngere pflanzen gibt die noch voll
power haben so dass wenn der ertrag bei
den einen weg fällt man immer noch die
anderen hat das ist ein richtig guter
puffer und das funktioniert super super
gut ich weiß für dieses jahr ist es zu
spät aber nächstes jahr unbedingt daran
denken und dann versuche ich auch die
pflanzen die anfällig für mehltau sind
egal für welchen von beiden typen immer
in mischkultur mit knoblauch anzubauen
mischkultur ist sowieso eine super
einfache möglichkeit um auf biologische
und natürliche art und weise dafür zu
sorgen dass der garten möglichst gesund
bleibt und der dritte punkt sind weitere
pflanzt abstände es ist bei diesen
ganzen pilz erkrankungen ganz wichtig
dass er viel luft zwischen den pflanzen
durch streichen kann damit die wenn die
einmal nass geworden sind immer schön
abtrocknen und da keine luft zwischen
den pflanzen steht deswegen immer darauf
achten die richtigen finanz abstände
einzuhalten aber wenn ihr hier seid dann
ist es wahrscheinlich auch schon zu spät
dann habt ihr ja wahrscheinlich schon
mit eurem pflanzen und deswegen sprechen
wir mal darüber was man dann unternimmt
als allererstes ist ganz wichtig dass
man alle befallenen blätter möglichst
frühzeitig ab macht und über den
hausmüll entsorgt einfach damit sich
keine weiteren pflanzen anstecken und
damit die gesunden blätter die noch an
eurem pflanzen sind auch möglichst noch
lange gesund bleiben es ist eigentlich
bei allen pflanzenkrankheiten ganz
wichtig dass man richtig schnell
reagiert sobald man sieht dass es den
pflanzen nicht gut geht und das hier ist
ein richtig schönes negativbeispiel
schweiz eine knappe woche unterwegs und
schaut mal wie diese gurken pflanze
aussieht da hätte man viel früher schon
was unternehmen müssen und wenn die
pflanze wirklich sehr sehr schlimm
befallen ist man aber noch jede menge
gesunde pflanzen im garten hat dann ist
es manchmal besser wenn man eine ganze
pflanze dann aus dem garten entfernt
weil die die anderen natürlich extrem
schnell anstecken kann ich versuche
jetzt trotzdem noch zu retten aber wenn
ich in den nächsten tagen merke dass das
ganze nicht funktioniert und keinen sinn
hat dann muss die leider in den hausmüll
wandern und dann ist schnappt ihr euch
eine spritze flasche dann habe ich jetzt
verschiedene optionen was ihr euch
zusammen tanzen könnt um eure pflanzen
damit einzusprühen damit sie möglichst
schnell wieder gesund werden ich finde
es immer gut wenn man das auch mit
hausmitteln machen kann deswegen jetzt
ein trick gegen den echten mehltau also
den weißen da besorgt ihr euch mal
rohmilch die gibt es meistens im
bioladen es ist nicht so ganz einfach
die zu bekommen ansonsten könnt ihr auch
versuchen normale milch und molke zu
nehmen das ist aber wahrscheinlich noch
schwieriger die zu kriegen und dann
müsst ihr die eins zu acht mit wasser
und sprüht damit eure von echten mehltau
befallenen pflanze nein das funktioniert
auch sehr sehr gut weil die nächste
bakterien die darin enthalten sind die
pilze an den kampf ansagen und gegen den
falschen mehltau hilft richtig gut ein
knoblauch süd knoblauch es ja auch ein
toller mischkultur partner damit die
pflanzen von vornherein möglichst gesund
bleiben aber der hilft auch wunderbar um
den falschen meter zu bekämpfen dafür
zerkleinert die einmal die zehn von
einer ganzen knolle knoblauch und dann
geht's dir die mit heißem wasser
aufnehmen dafür somit 500 milliliter da
ist das schön ziehen und abkühlen dann
habe ich den knoblauch raus und für das
ganze in eine sprit flasche und dann
auch einmal einnebeln das natürlich
immer wieder alle zwei drei tage
wiederholen bis es den pflanzen dann
wieder besser geht eine pflanze die
richtig häufig vom mieter betroffen ist
ist ja die gurke das ist super ärgerlich
weil das ist eins der leckersten gemüse
die man anbauen kann die sollen bitte
auch gut wachsen und deswegen schaut auf
jeden fall da trieben vorbei da habe ich
ein video zum thema gut aus ganzen
gemacht das ist eine wichtige
pflegemaßnahme der mitte und pflanzen
nicht vom mehltau befallen werden also
da auf jeden fall vorbei schauen und
dann geht raus macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für ein neues video teams